what's happening there reject nation that felt
weird to say because i'm usually sitting right
here and hearing it but now here i am on the
real rejects and i am very very excited for this
episode of koi's comic corner without greg or
john this feels very strange but regardless of
the lack of gregor john please leave a like and
subscribe and click that bell to get notified
when the next video is up now all of this is about
a huge announcement a leak that doesn't typically
happen with marvel the thunderbolts has been
leaked an announcement that rarely happens where
marvel didn't formally announce something but
it turns out the rumor is that jake schreier is
directing a thunderbolts property this is huge
rarely do we find anything out for marvel that
isn't carefully curated this makes a lot of sense
and a lot of companies are i think falsely touting
it as marvel's answer to the suicide squad now
we're gonna get into that we're gonna get into
who the thunderbolts are we're gonna get into a
possible lineup of the things assembled to date
that might make up the thunderbolts we're gonna
talk about who the possible villain might be why i
think the thunderbolts would be a game changer for
the mcu and of course some comic recommendations
for you folks if you want to know these characters
as well as i do before you get the thunderbolts
movie let's get after it all right so we know
who the director is theoretically but who are
the thunderbolts so the thunderbolts are a team
from the comics that are really interesting
because they're under the guise of being a super
team a lot of the avengers a lot of the defenders
a lot of fantastic four but they're actually
villains trying to basically rip off small towns
or make superhero antics profitable they're kind
of heroes for higher but more shenanigans are
involved but what's cool about the thunderbolts is
slowly they kind of develop a moral compass these
characters with powers these characters that have
often gotten away with doing horrible things of
their powers start to realize the error in their
ways and they can become good that's some of the
arcs in other arcs there are times when they stay
villainous in other arcs there are times that they
stay villains for the sake of their leader
and actually become heroes etc there's about
10 different thunderbolts teams this comic's
been around since the 90s and it's had about
42 main members and upwards of 80 various members
depending on the size of the team so this is a lot
of reading i'm trying to streamline for you guys
because it's hundreds and hundreds of issues of
comics but basically the thunderbolts are a team
that has that darth vader i am your father twist
where the american public or you know the european
public or wherever they're doing their heroism
gets revealed like oh no bullseye was helping
that wasn't actually daredevil etc so i think
the difference between this and the suicide squad
is that basically the suicide squad are known
villains that are trapped doing certain things for
the sake of their own survival so it's literally
just survivalism whereas the thunderbolts are a
team that are working under the guise of being
good guys and the average public doesn't know
they're bad and that's a huge huge important
difference because i think we're leading to a
different era in the mcu where heroes aren't
as beloved we've had tastes of it with civil war
we've had tastes of it with i think where we're
going with miss marvel and most importantly i
think it all leads to the biggest next shift
in the mcu the x-men unless there is a powder
keg for a world that hates and fears them the
x-men don't work so yes every single time someone
talks about marvel inevitably the x-men come up
anything in phase four inevitably people want
the x-men but i do think specifically the
thunderbolts is the gateway between miss marvel
and where we're going with the x-men that's where
we are now with my theoretical opinion of why the
thunderbolts matter let's talk about who might be
the thunderbolts from what we've gathered so far
in the mcu possible members i think i would have
them do a kind of big five to mirror the original
avengers back in phase one where you have that
beautiful shot of all them gathered together i
think it'd be beautiful symmetry to have that like
we've been hoodwinked these aren't heroes after
all i think they might even try to do it in movie
where they confuse the audience i think they might
gather these heroes and then make you realize oh
no i've been rooting for villains so i think they
might go elena belova as black widow they might
go us agent as captain america and they'll have
some interesting commentary there because we have
an audience if you watch the show have seen him do
horrible things but in the real world there's lots
and lots of ways to manipulate people's opinions
even though you've seen them do horrible things
you've also got abomination who i think is going
to be the you know hulk parallel we've got ghost
who we last saw in ant-man who's an actual member
in the comic books i think that's our first new
completely uh original ip member of this new
avengers team we've got taskmaster who's a very
important member from the comic books but i think
deserves a bit of a redemption arc i think of any
phase 4 movie black widows taskmaster situation is
the thing that's most maligned and if you haven't
noticed marvel does a very good job reading
message boards and going like oh no we messed
this up let's fix it a la thor the dark world look
at thor's dark world look at what they did the
avengers infinity war and endgame movies and tell
me they didn't go okay we read that message board
i think they might do the same with taskmaster by
having taskmaster be a very important part of this
thunderbolt situation and basically retconning
and fixing a lot of the issues we all have at that
character i also hope and this is the most i went
in order of insanity the craziest pitch would be
if you need an iron man you need someone that's
a crazy sleazy impossibly charming arrogant tech
billionaire sam rockwell bring back justin hammer
and his tanned hands give me an iron man that is
not doing things very selflessly give me that
selfish sam rockwell that just wants to profit
he'd be perfect in thunderbolts that's not cannon
to the comics but you know who is is whiplash
whiplash is a huge character from the comics and
i doubt mickey rourke and his bird want anything
to do with this franchise so instead you pluck
sam rockwell and that's the team i would assemble
also in the comic books winter soldier is a key
member often leading the team which i think would
be a really interesting twist if they have winter
soldier maybe be the villain of the story what if
the relationship with a certain character i'm
about to talk about and winter soldier causes a
bit of a oh no we don't know which side to root
for because we like these guys winter soldier
maybe we think he's brainwashed again maybe we're
not sure where his allegiances are but that's
because of baron zemo baron zemo is typically the
big reveal leader in the comic books he's under
the guise of this character citizen 5 citizen 5 or
v i only read it i'm not sure how it's pronounced
i don't know if he's referred to a citizen fiverr
citizen v but basically that character is revealed
to be baron zemo and that's how we find out these
heroes we've been following are in fact villains
the american public i mean i think by the end
of the show when they call it captain america
in the winter soldier we see beren zemo who he's
loved and has been charming is still duplicitous
is still capable of evil things i think it'd be
really fun to have him as the villain as he is the
core thunderbolt leader but in addition to that
we do have norman osborne as the leader at times
we have had even the punisher as the leader of the
thunderbolts and the one you're gonna read a lot
about in the internet is general thunderbolt ross
now thunderbolt ross isn't the leader until like
the fourth or fifth iteration of the thunderbolts
but i do think thunderbolt ross would be a very
interesting captivating choice because it would
deal with the military industrial complex it'll
deal with the commentary from the civil war about
the government against heroes it would deal with
a lot of the commentary we're living through now
where it's like what do we do with these systems
of power who do we trust so obviously we we have
lost william hurt that does complicate things i
don't know if they would want to do a general ross
all cgi would he stay red hulk with that glorious
mustache and maybe some voice over would we have
a new military character basically playing a
parallel to thunderbolt ross any of those things
are options but i do think the most likely
is baron zemo and that would allow some fun
friction with winter soldier and he's already
in these properties collecting black widow and
u.s agent and these things i think that is the
most likely scenario and i really want to see
daniel brule back and playing around with morality
duplicitousness and overall being charming and us
being like i like this guy why am i rooting for
him he's doing horrible things now the question is
we have the team assembled we have our potential
leader but who are they fighting i don't think
winter soldier will be the main core villain i
think it'll be a hiccup i think it'll be a problem
i think it'll be something to solve but what i
think they're gonna do and what i hope they do
what i would do is we met a certain officer at
the end of miss marvel that we'd already met in
no way home you should recognize that cop officer
whatever you want to call it the department of
damage control they've turned from in the comics
a cleanup agency we briefly saw them in spider-man
homecoming they're the people that took away
vultures livelihood they're the people that took
away all of his assets because that's what they do
in the comic books they clean up after superhero
supervillain fights it's a really cool concept
there was actually fun fact almost an abc show
about the department of damage control i think we
saw the long game they were going to include them
in the movies and that's why that show is crap
but i digress the department of damage control
seems to also be a bit of a policing force the
department of damage control i think is going
to start going after heroes that are under age i
think the effects of civil war are still following
up into phase four we've got lots of cosmic things
going on we've got battles with gods we've got
lots of huge threats but if you're doing a marvel
property you still need the ground level threat
the beautiful thing about the mcu and the thing
that keeps the comic book so interesting is while
you're in the sky you're also still in the ground
you've got characters like punisher you've got
characters like spider-man you've got characters
like miss marvel that handle jersey city threat
while you have those things you need a government
situation you had cap'n and hydro but you also had
cap versus shield i think when the sokovia accords
didn't go through now those same people that want
superheroes registered that want superheroes made
illegal that want registration around human beings
which is a very very very important conversation
to have about what it is to be made illegal what
you do is we couldn't make it so masks are illegal
because there's barely any masks in the mcu that's
what differs from the comic book so we had those
sakovia chords or is basically iron man versus
cap about registration they can carry that on
into this new team of young avengers who are
gonna be wearing masks who are gonna be underage
and the question doesn't become can these people
with powers act it'll be can these people that
aren't adults yet make decisions that affect the
world what do you do with someone that's 16 that
has the power to blankety blank what do you do
with someone who can lift a car if they can't
yet drive one what do you do with that and that's
what i think they'll have this registration act
be now and in the comic book there's a huge
precedent for this it's called kamala's law
if you watch our video reacting to episode one i
do cover briefly kamala's law in the essence of
it basically being the champions which are a very
important team in the comics they're more street
level but they're also much more political they
talk about climate change they talk about voters
registration rights they handle day-to-day human
city issues and the champions one of them gets
hurt miss marvel kamala khan and when she gets
hurt they are able to mask this thing called
kamala's law when they pass kamala's law it means
miles morales it means viv vision who's a young
female vision the daughter of vision it means all
of these wasps all of these young superheroes that
are friends with kamala are now hunted in her
name she's in a coma it is extra painful because
not only is it dragging her name through the
dirt while she's in a coma but they're worried
about her friend and they're hunting people under
the name kamala which is a very very interesting
feeling of what do we do about this while not
revealing our friend's identity what do we do
about this while we're also still trying to
have regular lives what do we do we're kids
we can't turn to the adults so it's a very
beautiful spiritual sequel and direct sequel
to civil war both in the comic books and i think
in the movies and who better to hunt down the
young avengers than a team of heroes that are
registered that are a more official police force
that are then revealed maybe in movie to be
bad guys and that allows us the audience to go
okay now the young avengers have someone to fight
it's not good guy versus good guy it's good guy
versus good guy that's actually bad guy i think
it'd be an incredible twist to see these heroes
revealed to be villains and that gives credence
to our young avengers for fighting them and it
makes us all realize that just registering them
isn't enough that there needs to be accountability
beyond these things and i think it'd be a very
interesting story about the importance of some
legislation and the importance of trust i think
by the end of the thunderbolts we're going to
set up a world where some heroes might be illegal
where some heroes aren't trusted where we can have
a world that hates and fears them setting up the
x-men and i think it all starts with episode two
of miss marvel which is coming out right now i
almost guarantee you we start to see groundwork
laid throughout ms marvel and we might even see
kamala's law passed by episode six setting us up
directly for the thunderbolts this is huge this is
winter soldier level getting us to the point where
shield unravels setting up everything in phase
three i think phase four is much more cohesive
than people are giving it credit for i think
we're getting a lot more properties and therefore
a lot more breadcrumbs we just don't see what
that loaf of bread is yet that bread's cooking
and it's coming and it's going to be awesome
that's what i think thunderbolts is going to be
i think it's going to be a big bait and switch i
think it's going to be really special for the mcu
and i think it's going to lead to even bigger
things so yes we don't have an avengers right
now but i think we're gonna have young avengers
i think we're gonna have a thunderbolts and i
think it's gonna blow people's minds when those
characters are revealed to be villains and that's
why they're different than the suicide squad i'm
so excited i cannot wait to see the thunderbolts
it's a comic team i love from the books i would
recommend you check out not just the original
run from mark bagley some of the most beautiful
stuff with baron zemo running the thunderbolts
check out the more recent dark rain run where
norman osborne is running them and if you want
a more x-force-centric team there's a really fun
run with deadpool elektra and those characters
you're probably more familiar with that came out
in 06 or thereabouts so there's a lot of great
stuff that one's called marvel now thunderbolts
you can find that in a trade paperback form
if you guys want any recommendations any specific
issues or arcs leave a comment below i'll try
to respond to it or tweet at me etc i'll give you
guys more thunderbolt recommendations if you want
them but i would check out the original run mark
bagley art it's long it's glorious i would check
out the norman osborne dark rain stuff and
i would check out the marvel now stuff with
deadpool on the team those are the three runs i
think we might pull some influences from we'll
see when thunderbolts drops hopefully in the
next two years it's exciting stuff we'll see if
this league's getting more coverage at d23 i feel
like they're gonna make an official announcement
in the coming months well this was my first
solo video hopefully you guys enjoyed it it was
literally just me talking but for the
record greg was here the whole time
all right like subscribe leave a comment
turn that bell on other youtube things
thank you reject nation for welcoming me with
open arms thank you for loving those first two
videos and thank you so much for not saying screw
this guy talks too fast about comics too much we
don't want him on the channel cause i appreciate
being here much loved you guys see you next time
you